hello welcome to the Daily climate show
coming up today developing nations take
the stage at cop 27 demanding
compensation from richer countries and
fossil fuel companies for the damage
caused by climate change while they are
profiting the planet is burning
the UK pledges 200 million pounds to
help Africa's green adaptation but there
are questions over how soon the
continent can move away from gas
and how the result of today's midterm
elections could test the United States
commitment to climate action
[Music]
hi there good to see you on the daily
climate show where we track the changes
to our world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now one of the big themes of this
year's cop 27 Summit is climate
reparations that's essentially
compensation paid to those Nations that
have suffered most from climate change
at the hands of those who have
contributed the most emissions countries
affected by extreme weather and slow
onset events such as melting ice are
asking big polluting Nations to pay up
that is in addition to the 100 billion
dollars a year promised by Rich Nations
to developing countries by 2020 a Target
that has been repeatedly missed Pakistan
is among those asking for help earlier
this year extreme flooding in Pakistan
is estimated to have killed more than
one and a half thousand people and
caused 40 billion dollars worth of
damage small islands and low-lying
Coastal developing nations vulnerable to
rising sea levels have been asking for
help for some time and who could forget
this address from cop26 in Glasgow last
year the foreign minister of tuvalu a
country of nine small low-lying Islands
warning it may soon become uninhabitable
but in the last hour the prime minister
of Pakistan recounted how his Nation had
suffered from these extreme floods
an estimate of damage and loss
has exceeded 30 billion dollars
and this all happened despite our very
low
carbon footprints
and yet
we became a victim of
something
with which we had nothing to do
and of course
it was a man-made disaster
and a little earlier the prime minister
of the Caribbean Nation Antigua and
Barbuda echoed calls for richer
countries to stump up more cash to help
small Nations Gustin Brown also said
fossil fuel companies should pay a
global carbon tax on their profits
it is about time that these companies
are made to pay a global carbon tax on
your profits
as a source of funding for loss in
damage
profligate producers of fossil fuels
have benefited from extortionate profits
at the expense of human civilization
while they are profiting the planet is
burning loss and damage should not be
seen through divisive and controversial
lands
but as a form of climate Justice
well to our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter who's
at [ __ ] 27 in Egypt Hannah not everyone
sold on this idea of reparations or
compensation but Pakistan's leader
suggesting some kind of index how would
that work
yes a vulnerable Nations index to help
establish who is owed the money frankly
that's that's what Pakistan's prime
minister is asking for you know there
are lots of ideas about how this loss
and damage funding might work me and
Motley the Prime Minister of Barbados
calling as well for a global tax on
fossil fuel companies I just spoke to
her actually and she she told me in no
uncertain terms that it doesn't really
matter uh you know what what developed
which nations think but that this is an
idea whose time has come she compared it
to the suffragettes movement but there
is a certain reality to all of this and
that is that the US in particular and
other Rich nations are really reluctant
to do any more than just talk about loss
and damage at the moment there is
certainly a real reluctance to go any
further in terms of creating a new
funding facility that is not on the
table at all rich countries much prefer
to divert funds to those in Need by our
existing infrastructure like for example
various U.N agencies and the World Bank
and the World Health Organization and so
on
and therefore at the moment unless
anything radical shifts there's only a
handful of countries rich ones anyway
who've agreed to even countenance
putting money into a separate pot for
developing nations vulnerable to climate
change to access all right Hannah I'll
back to you in just a moment first
though the United Kingdom has pledged
200 million pounds to help African
nations transition to a Greener future
but questions remain about just how that
money is going to be spent let's hear
from the presidents of Ghana and South
Africa speaking about why their
continent needs help in the fight
against climate change
our continent will need a predictable
appropriate
and at scale funding stream and
technological support
Africa is the greatest potential to help
decarbonize the world it is critical in
this regard that the developed world
makes good his long delayed pledge to
mobilize and make available 100 million
dollar billion dollars annually to the
poorer countries to assist in the fight
against climate change
so that is the case for investment but
some governments on the African
continent have expressed frustration at
being told how to spend any financial
support cop 27 hosts Egypt and also
Algeria believe they should be allowed
to use more gas a fossil fuel to supply
power to their people and let us look at
why at present 600 million people lack
access to electricity most of them in
sub-Saharan Africa that is 43 of the
continent's population more than 5 000
billion cubic meters of natural gas
resources have been discovered in Africa
but not yet approved for development
renewable Advocates say there should be
no more investment in gas especially in
new infrastructure emissions from use of
these gas resources over the next 30
Years would be around 10 gigatons if
added to Africa's total today they would
would bring its share of global emission
to three and a half percent Let Us
return to Hannah now in Egypt so this
new funding for the African nations some
questions though over whether the
continent is actually prioritizing
fossil fuels or Renewables
but he wants to do both
um and and the position of countries
like Senegal the gas producing Nation
want to sell gas to Germany and Algeria
the gas producing nation is that we have
to lift our own people out of poverty we
have to give them access to electricity
600 million people on the continent
without access to electricity at the
moment they want to create growth they
want to they want to enjoy all the
benefits of consuming energy that
Western Nations have traditionally and
of course they did it exclusively with
dirty fossil fuels and helped to drive
this crisis at the same time of course
they want to invest in Renewables and
their position is that this is about
Justice why can't we do both things
all right Hannah many thanks indeed
Hannah Thomas Peter
now earlier this year the United States
Congress approved a major climate Bill
directing 370 billion dollars into
renewable energy production and reducing
greenhouse gases it was seen as a major
climate Victory with one of the world's
biggest polluters taking a new Direction
bringing a quick reminder of who the
world's biggest polluters are China is
the world's biggest the rest of the top
five made up by the U.S India Russia and
Japan none of these countries leaders
are in charmel Sheikh today although we
do know that Joe Biden will join the
summit after the U.S midterm election
results the question is though would
defeat for Joe Biden's Democrats in
these elections make it harder for him
to deliver on that climate agenda well
the director of independent Think Tank
e3g's DC office Claire Healy joins me
now good to see you Claire so quick
prediction what you think might happen
in the midterms
so I'm not a pollster I have to say and
the posters often get it wrong but the
latest polls indicate the Republicans
will take back control of the house and
the Senate there's a handful of races
and it's still a toss-up that we're
watching to see who controls the Senate
what happens then to this climate Bill
we know Donald Trump and plenty of
Republicans opposition
um could it be stymied
the quick answer is no it could be
slowed down and short a republican
Congress could indeed stop energy but
there's three big bills that this
Congress have passed and now laws and
the tax incentives uh that they you know
provide to many states blue States and
red states have been inscribed into the
tax code as of January the 1st so that
can't be undone I do think in the past a
republican Congress has meant Doom for
climate policy and a bit of a whiplash
the U.S climate diplomacy I do think
there are reasons today to be a bit more
pragmatic and a bit more optimistic and
there's been a lot of progress done
under the past two years of the Biden
Administration and that progress it
can't stop and it won't stop and I think
regardless of the outcome of the
midterms we can still make progress uh
in the next two years and do you think
there could be some kind of consensus
with Republicans any kind of compromise
so I mean I don't want to come across as
a pollyanna-ish for sure I think many of
the Republicans perhaps will be
obstructionists and for sure they'll
have a robust oversight but I think
there are at least three sets of reasons
why Republicans will be a bit more
pragmatic and that's number one on the
economy side I think Republicans have
warmed up to more of an industrial
policy and they can see building the
clean energy economy makes the us more
competitive with China number two on the
politics side the way the IRA the
inflation reduction act has been written
into law many of those powerful tax
incentives go to Red States indeed much
of the infrastructure is being built in
Republican strongholds and rural areas
so it's quite popular and number three
from an electoral point of view while
we're talking today about the midterms
and for sure Uh Kevin McCarthy wants to
become speaker of the house but they
know I think for their longer term
electoral success climate and
environment have to be a core part of
their platform because one the American
public want it they're feeling the
impacts just like you're reporting uh
from charm or Sheikh the reality is such
that the impacts are being felt
Americans want more climate action not
less
economy I have something there Claire uh
because we're out of time but thank you
very much indeed for joining us Claire
Healy
thank you now don't forget you can get
to all the latest news from cop27 on our
live blog just scan the QR code on
screen right now and just before we go a
reminder that our weekly climate Show
with Tom Heap is back that is on
Saturdays and Sundays at 3 30 in the
afternoon or at 7 30 in the evening but
that is it for today so thank you if
your company join us tomorrow for the
very latest from cop27 and the rest of
the news affecting the planet from all
the team bye-bye foreign